yeah it's kind of interesting
the history of cryptocurrency has this
um
tension of really good ideas that are
hard to implement
so they take longer to implement and
ideas
that are not as good but are faster to
implement this is like the story of like
you have like javascript that basically
took over the world
because it was quick to implement within
10 days
and then like later kept fixing itself
i i don't know what to make of that sort
of from an engineering perspective
i'm more and more becoming comfortable
and accepting the fact that our whole
world will run a technology that's
not as good as it could have been just
because
the crappy solution is faster to
implement and it sticks
what do you make of that tension i think
the
compromise that we've been taking within
ethereum is
like when we have to take the crappy
solution we look for crappy solutions
that are forward compatible with
becoming good over time
right like when you build the the quick
and dirty thing like you could
you would still already have ideas in
your head about
you know what the the more complete
thing with all the security features
added on would look like right even if
it requires a hard fork
um yes like even so you know like for
example we're sharding right like well
yeah i think
it's the likely that the first version
of chardonnay that comes out like is not
going to have you know zika snarks and
data availability sampling for example
but we know what these technologies are
we feel like we
you know have wrapped our heads around
them and so we know how to build a
system
where we can put all the pieces in place
so that it becomes very easy to bolt
those components on in the future
uh so like if you do things that way
right then
at the beginning you can have your
system that has the functionality but
say has less security or like less
sustainability or less of something else
but then over time like it's designed in
such a way that it has this easy on
on-ramp to adding those things
right and if you don't think explicitly
about like being future compatible then
you do often end up with a quick and
dirty solution that backs you into a
corner
and then there are definitely cases
where like i think the ethereum
ecosystem has suffered from that and we
have had to
like expand pretty significant effort
on for example removing features that we
didn't realize
that we actually can't sustain like one
big example is just increasing the yeah
the gas costs so like making some
operations more expensive when they
because they should be expensive because
they actually take a lot of time in the
process
and um so that's you know making a thing
some things more expensive kind of like
taking some functionality away
um so if you can like be cognizant of
where
you're likely going into the future and
if you don't know like even be cognizant
of both the most likely paths that
you'll take in the future
and coming like thinking about your road
map and coming up with a road map where
you know that like if you wants to do
either of those things then you have a
clean path toward it
that's probably the best kind of
practical way to get the best of both
worlds that we have
you